If because there was moose, goose, loose, noose. I mentioned this on my other podcast, Arraycast. Check it out every two weeks on Saturday. What is this? No, no, absolutely not. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 65, recorded on February 5th, 2022. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we mention the CPP North call for papers deadline, which is on February 21st, the positions that NVIDIA is currently hiring for, and then
如果是因为有moose、goose、loose、noose这些词。我在我的另一个播客Arraycast上提到了这个。每两周的周六去看看吧。这是什么？不，不，绝对不是。欢迎来到ADSP播客第65集，录制于2022年2月5日。我是康纳（Connor），今天和我的联合主持布莱斯（Bryce）一起，我们提到了CPP North（C++北美会议）的论文征集截止日期（是2月21日），NVIDIA目前正在招聘的职位，然后
Bryce gives me a custom Wordle to solve live. It's the return of hat Connor, of baseball cap connor what's up what's good reverse baseball cap connor i can't see your hair buddy where's your hair i gotta see those locks god we haven't talked in like a while because well not uh yeah not not one-on-one i mean january 15th was the last time we recorded it is Really? Wow, that feels like Yeah, I mean, it's February 5th We can announce What are we doing here?
布莱斯给我出了一个定制版的Wordle让我现场解答。这是戴帽子的康纳（hat Connor）的回归，棒球帽康纳（baseball cap connor），最近怎么样？戴反向棒球帽的康纳，我看不见你的头发，老兄，你的头发呢？我得看看那些卷发。天哪，我们已经好久没聊天了，因为，呃，没，对，没单聊，我是说，1月15日是我们上次录制的时间。真的吗？哇，感觉就像，对，我是说，今天是2月5日，我们可以宣布。我们在这儿干嘛呢？
We can announce a couple things How are we doing this? Well, first we're playing Wordle Because I can't Wait, let me I just gotta type down a couple things So I don't forget to bring them up in the next episode. Oh, I got an appointment for an important...
我们可以宣布几件事。我们怎么在弄这个？好吧，首先我们在玩Wordle。因为我不能，等等，让我，我得把几件事打下来，免得我在下一集里忘了提。哦，我有一个重要预约……
Let me try that sentence again. I got an important first announcement, which is that I am hiring C++ compiler engineers. So if you want to come and work at NVIDIA on exciting new C++ compilers, send me a DM or an email or a smoke signal or a letter or find me on the streets of Manhattan. Any of those options work. Any of those options work. Are we going to post a N you know, NVIDIA portal, like, job description? No?
让我再试一次那个句子。我有一个重要的第一条公告，那就是我正在招聘C++编译器工程师。所以如果你想来NVIDIA从事激动人心的全新C++编译器工作，给我发私信、发邮件、发狼烟、发信件，或者在曼哈顿的街头找到我。这些选项都可以。这些选项都可以。我们要发一个N，你知道的，NVIDIA门户网站那样的职位描述吗？不？
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Because you have to email me and then I refer you. And then I refer you. That may be because that is the way that Bryce gets the referral bonus. But also that's the way that I make sure that the HR team actually brings you in for an interview interview like i looked your resume and like i'm like oh yeah this person's good and then i'm like hey bring in this person for an interview yep juicy content um you're figuring out why bryce really does it let's be honest someone may well of the two of us one of us may have gotten a hiring bonus for bringing the other person into our current company.
不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。因为你必须给我发邮件，然后我推荐你。然后我推荐你。那可能是因为那是布莱斯拿到推荐奖金的方式。但这也是我确保人力资源团队真正带你来面试的方式，面试，就像我看你的简历，然后我说：“哦，对，这个人不错。”然后我说：“嘿，带这个人来面试。”是的，多汁的内容。嗯，你发现为什么布莱斯 realmente（实际上）要这么做了。老实说，我们俩当中，可能有一个人因为把另一个人拉进我们目前的公司而得到了招聘奖金。
I still owe you like a fancy dinner. Don't wait. Don't you owe me a fancy dinner from that? I don't want to talk about that. I don't want to talk about that. I owe you like a very, I owe you at least one very fancy dinner and one somewhat fancy dinner from the bet about the Prague committeeg uh uh committee meeting video which i was hoping that like the pandemic would make you forget that i i had promised to take you to like
我还是欠你一顿高级大餐。别等了。难道你不欠我一顿那次的高级大餐吗？我不想谈这个。我不想谈这个。关于布拉格委员会，呃，呃，委员会会议视频的打赌，我欠你大约一个非常，我欠你至少一顿非常高级的大餐和一顿有点高级的大餐。我本希望疫情能让你忘掉我曾答应带你去……
that i had lost a bet that involved me taking you to a 300 a person sushi restaurant but that sushi restaurant was in in california like where neither of us live there still. Oh, yeah. So if I can get reservations, which I'm almost certain I can't, I'll take you to Eleven Madison Park instead, which is a three Michelin star restaurant in New York that apparently has recently switched to like an all vegetarian menu or maybe it's all vegan.
我输了一个赌局，内容是带你去一家人均300美元的寿司店，但那家寿司店在加利福尼亚州，我们俩都不住在那里。哦，对。所以如果我能订到位子——我几乎可以肯定我订不到——我会带你去十一麦迪逊公园（Eleven Madison Park），那是纽约的一家米其林三星餐厅，据说最近改成了全素菜单，或者可能是纯素的。
It's fine with me. And the reviews are like not great um but i'm like not famous enough to to get reservations there but i'll try for you for you i appreciate that whenever i make it down to uh new york so that's uh so nvidia's hiring and i guess uh i was gonna say i'll announce that cpp north call for papers is open however yeah i submitted my time by the time that this or i should have been in my keynotes right because you're gonna make me a keynote right it's uh no but but who are the keynotes i hear we have some pretty exciting keynotes for we do we have two of our keynotes announced uh sean parent and kate gregory two of like the best speakers in c++ yeah uh it's
我没意见。而且评论好像不是很好，嗯，但我还不够红，订不到那里的位子，不过我会为了你试一试的。我很感激，每当我去纽约的时候，呃，所以这就是，所以NVIDIA在招聘，我想，呃，我本来要说，我要宣布CPP North的论文征集已经开始了，不过，嗯，我提交我的时间是在这个，或者我本该在我的主题演讲里，对吧？因为你要让我做主题演讲，对吧？是，呃，不，但主题演讲嘉宾都有谁？我听说我们有一些非常令人兴奋的主题演讲嘉宾，我们有两位已公布的主题演讲嘉宾：肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent）和凯特·格雷戈里（Kate Gregory），他们是C++领域最优秀的两位演讲者。是的，呃，这
pretty exciting pretty exciting unfortunately though by the time this airs i mean our first wordle episode that we recorded i believe on the 15th which is the last time we recorded just was out yesterday on february 4th yeah yeah and so by the time this one goes out it's going to be like tail end of February and Call for Papers is actually closed. So thanks to the podcast editing gods. This episode is actually coming out on February 18th, three days before the Call for Papers for CPP North
挺让人兴奋的，挺让人兴奋的。不过遗憾的是，等这期节目播出时，我是说，我们录制的第一个Wordle节目——我相信是在15号，也就是我们上次录制的时间——刚刚在昨天2月4日发布。对，对，所以等这期节目播出时，将近2月底了，论文征集其实已经截止了。所以感谢播客剪辑之神。这期节目实际上会在2月18日播出，也就是CPP North论文征集截止日期前三天——
closes on February 21st at 1159 p.m. Eastern Standard Time Zone. So if you have been on the fence about submitting, this conference is going to be in person. We are aiming to design a super inclusive conference that highlights not just experienced speakers that you've seen at other conferences before, but new speakers that you've never seen before. So if you have been hesitant about submitting to other conferences in the past, this is definitely the time to submit now. Back to the episode. Wait, really? We have that much back like so we didn't mean to record
论文征集将于2月21日东部标准时间晚上11点59分截止。所以，如果你一直在犹豫要不要投稿，这次会议将是线下举办的。我们的目标是设计一个超级包容的会议，不仅突出你在其他会议上见过的经验丰富的演讲者，还突出你从未见过的新演讲者。所以，如果你过去对向其他会议投稿感到犹豫，现在绝对是投稿的时候。回到正题。等等，真的吗？我们积压了那么多——所以我们本来没打算这周录音，因为你有很多关于下一期——哦，对，我们积压了至少一期，可能两期节目，但没关系，因为我们还没赶上进度，而且我们绝对，呃，这就是情况：上次录音时，我只玩了八次Wordle。而且我觉得我的策略很不成熟。是的，我觉得我们的策略依然……所以，听众朋友们，你们必须明白，Wordle已经接管了我们的生活。我现在每天花20到30分钟玩Wordle。然后我和康纳会进行总结复盘，大概有，呃，可能差不多30分钟到一个小时的来回讨论，
this week because you had enough stuff for next oh yeah we've got at least one maybe two episodes on the backlog but it's all right because we haven't caught up and we definitely uh this is the thing so the last time we recorded i had only played Wordle eight times. And I would say that my strategy was unsophisticated. Yeah, I think our strategy is still... So, listener, you have to understand that Wordle has taken over our life. I now spend 20 to 30 minutes a day playing the Wordle. And then Connor and I have a debrief, which is, like, I don't know, probably a good 30 minutes to an hour of back and forth of
这周因为你积攒的内容已经够多了哦，对，我们积压了至少一期，可能两期节目，但没关系，因为我们还没赶上进度，而且绝对……事情是这样的，上次录音时我才玩了八次Wordle，而且我可以说我的策略很不成熟。对，我觉得我们的策略还是……所以，听众朋友们，你们得明白，Wordle已经占领了我们的生活。我现在每天花20到30分钟玩Wordle，然后康纳和我还要进行复盘，也就是大概，可能足足30分钟到一小时的讨论，
us talking about Wordle strategy. It's just become a part of our, like every day, every day. And then, and then my new thing is that we're going to start just playing Wordle like amongst ourselves. Like I have a word today. It's going to be really rough for Connor. We're going to, we're going to have him play it live and we're going to see if he gets it. So here's the thing. Someone pointed out recently that I say that a lot. Here's the thing. And so now anytime I say that, I catch myself saying it. The New York Times, so update about Wordle.
讨论我们的Wordle策略。这已经成了我们日常的一部分，每天都是如此。然后，然后我的新想法是，我们要开始在内部玩Wordle了。就像我今天有个词，对康纳来说会很难，我们要让他现场玩，看看他能不能猜出来。所以是这样的，最近有人指出我经常说这句话：“是这样的。”所以现在每次我说这句话时，我都会意识到自己在说。纽约时报，关于Wordle的最新消息。
The New York Times has purchased Wordle. I mentioned this on my other podcast, Arraycast. Check it out every two weeks on Saturday. What is this? No, no, absolutely not. Is Bryce jealous? Yes. Is Bryce a jealous podcast co-host? So the point being is that our streaks, everything, let's be honest, the New York Times is going to, they're going to mess that up. They're going to mess that up. I was going use a more a stronger like two days ago messed up my streak anyway so whatever but the point is is wordle's going away so for those of you for the listener for you thinking i came here
纽约时报收购了Wordle。我在我的另一个播客Arraycast里提到过这个，每两周的周六记得收听。这是什么？不，不，绝对不行。布莱斯在嫉妒吗？是的。布莱斯是个会嫉妒的播客联合主持人吗？所以重点是，我们的连胜记录，所有这一切，说实话，纽约时报会把事情搞砸的。他们会把事情搞砸的。我本来想用一个更强烈的词，两天前反正我的连胜也被毁了，所以无所谓了，但重点是Wordle快没了，所以对于你们这些听众，对于那些以为我是来
for juicy algorithm data structure content uh don't worry these wordle episodes they're ephemeral they're only here for a limited time only special no because because wordle you don't need the website to play Wordle. You just need a friend. That's true. But the exciting part is actually doing it live. Anyways, we had unsophisticated. So back then, our starting word was tears.
听干货算法和数据结构内容的人，别担心，这些Wordle节目只是昙花一现，限时特供，不，因为玩Wordle你根本不需要官方网站，你只需要一个朋友。没错。但令人兴奋的部分其实是现场连线。总之，我们当时很不成熟。所以那时，我们的起始词是tears。
Since then, our starting word, or at least my starting word, has been a rose. Yeah, and I've used that too. But I apparently, I've learned recently that that is not actually the optimal word. Some people on TikTok had figured out like the best first word based not only on letter frequency, but also on if that word is a miss, how many like options does it eliminate? And so I heard that like irate is a really good one. And there's a few others that are like better than that. But I hear that arose is not the best one.
从那以后，我们的起始词，或者至少是我的起始词，变成了arose。对，我也用过那个。但我显然最近了解到，那其实并不是最佳单词。TikTok上有些人找出了最佳首发词，不仅基于字母频率，还基于如果这个词猜错，它能排除多少选项。所以我听说irate是一个非常好的词，还有其他几个比它更好。但我听说arose并不是最好的。
Although we have had good success with it. Except for like two days ago when I got just absolutely wrecked. And don't want to talk about it. I'm still emotional. Yeah, it's understandable. That was a tricky one. The word Bryce is referring to is shard. And honestly honestly there's
虽然我们用它取得了不错的成绩。除了像两天前我被虐得很惨的那次，我不想谈这个，我现在还很情绪化。是的，可以理解。那确实是个棘手的词。布莱斯提到的词是shard，说实话，说实话，
been a couple words now where i've been real concerned even what was it pleat the other day oh pleat was tough these words were the worst situation because i've realized that this was never intentional but i've always played in hard code hardcore mode which is where you always use your information so like in our last Wordle episode, we talked about going from tears to found or hound. That is not hard code, hardcore mode, because you're not using the A that you know is in the word. So hardcore is where you always use that information. So some people, they just choose three random words that don't overlap, like arose until, and then some third word. So
现在有几个词让我真的很担心，比如前几天那个pleat，哦，pleat太难了。这些词简直是最糟糕的情况，因为我意识到，虽然我从来不是故意的，但我一直都在玩硬核模式，也就是你必须每次都用上已知的信息。所以在我们上一期Wordle节目中，我们谈到了从tears到found或hound的转变。那不是硬核模式，因为你没有使用那个你已经知道存在于单词中的A。所以硬核模式是指你必须始终使用这些已知信息。所以有些人，他们只选择三个互不重叠的随机单词，比如arose、until，再加上第三个词，所以
then you get like a really good, you know, set of, if not all five, but you know, four out of five of your words, and you can probably make a decent guess. But that is not hardcore mode. Well, no, I think that's harder than our way of playing. I think it depends on the word. Sometimes it'll make it incredibly easy if you know all five letters and, you know, one of them, the right position and the other, the four. I like how there's like, there's now there's like schools of thought for how to play Wordle. Yeah. But the trickiest situation, in my opinion, is where you get down to four green letters. Yeah.
这样你就能得到一套非常好的，即使不是全部五个，但也能有四个字母的组合，你大概能做一个不错的猜测。但那不是硬核模式。好吧，不，我觉得那比我们的玩法更难。我觉得这取决于单词。有时候如果你知道全部五个字母，其中一个位置正确，另外四个位置也知道，这会让游戏变得异常简单。我喜欢现在玩Wordle居然还分门别派了。是的。但在我看来，最棘手的情况是当你只剩下四个绿色的字母。是的。
And you have one missing one. And there are multiple options because you're hooped then. For the day that I, for the day that we had Pleat, I had all four letter – I had all five letters just out of place. So I think that like – and I guess – I think I guessed like plate before pleat. Yeah. Yeah. I can tell based on your letters. It was like either petal or plate or something like that.
而你还缺一个。而且会有多个选项，因为那样你就陷入困境了。在我遇到pleat的那天，我所有的四个字母——我所有的五个字母都找出来了，只是位置不对。所以我觉得——我想——我猜在pleat之前我猜的是plate。是的。是的。我从你的字母就能看出来。大概是petel或者plate之类的。
No, maybe it was petal. I think it was petal. I think it was petal. Yeah. So my second guess just luckily was petal. And I've also realized that – so on the day that it was Pleat, we guessed a rose that had A and E. And I've realized that like rarely do words end in S as like plural nouns or do they end in ED as in a past tense verb. So a lot of the times I would typically guess in the past like caned, C-A-N-E-D.
不，也许是petel。我觉得是petel。我觉得是petel。是的。所以我的第二个猜测很幸运地是petel。而且我也意识到——所以在是pleat的那天，我们猜了包含A和E的arose。我发现单词很少以S结尾作为复数名词，也很少以ED结尾作为过去式动词。所以我很多时候通常会去猜过去式，比如caned，C-A-N-E-D。
Rarely ever does the word end in E-D. So now I've started to try and go for more like atypical words like metal, which ended up turning out really well. But in the case of metal, I knew that it ended up, because my third guess was cleat, but then you end up with pleat and bleat as your two other options. And luckily, I had gotten to the point where I had more guesses than I had possible words left. But there were certain days like when I ended up guessing moose as my third guess, and you'd called me so Canadian. Yes. And what that was those. In that case, I had OSE at the end. And I wasn't sure if because there was moose, goose, loose, noose. I think loose I had already rolled out because I'd used an l but the point
单词以E-D结尾的情况非常少见。所以我现在开始尝试一些更非典型的词，比如metal，结果证明效果非常好。但在metal这个词的情况下，我知道它是以……因为我的第三个猜测是cleat，但最后你剩下的其他两个选项是pleat和bleat。幸运的是，我当时剩下的猜测次数比可能的剩余单词还要多。但也有某些日子，比如当我把moose作为第三个猜测时，你叫我太加拿大人了。是的。那是怎么回事。在这种情况下，结尾是OSE。我不确定是不是因为有moose、goose、loose、noose。我想loose我已经排除掉了，因为我用过l，但重点
being is that i got really worried that day because if it was going to be a double o word i didn't i didn't i don't think i had enough guesses to go through all of moose goose noose and at that point like it's just luck of the draw and like the one that like scares me well no i'm not going to tell you the one that scares me because at some point i'm going to make you play for the one that scares me part of uh point I'm going to make you play for the one that scares me. Part of this ongoing every three or four episodes now, the way I edit it, we'll do Wordle, is I will introduce a couple valid Wordle words that probably people don't know. Because if we want to keep this streak alive, however long this lasts, we need to start to learn these words. So in the last episode, when we were trying to come up with words that were like in the pattern of basin or nadir that were A, I in the second and fourth position or in those reversed that didn't have T, R, S or E in them, there ended up being eight.
是，那天我真的很担心，如果这是一个双o的单词，我——我不觉得我有足够的猜测次数去把moose、goose、noose都试一遍，到了那个地步，就只能靠运气了。而且让我害怕的那个词——不，我不打算告诉你哪个词让我害怕，因为某些时候我要让你为了那个让我害怕的词来玩。部分……现在每隔三四期节目，我剪辑的方式就是加入Wordle环节，我会介绍几个大家可能不太熟悉的有效Wordle单词。因为如果我们想保持这个连胜记录，无论这能持续多久，我们需要开始学习这些单词。所以在上一期节目中，当我们试图找出像basin或nadir那种在第二和第四个位置有A、I，或者字母顺序相反且不包含T、R、S或E的词时，最后发现有八个。
There was 49 of them, I think, because we looked up and using all the letters T, R and S, there was like 127. I looked it up. There was 49, but only eight of them were valid word or words. And let's see if I can remember them off the top of my head. So the one that we guessed, cabin, was one of them. And then there was magic, panic, manic, which actually I was very confident that I knew the word. It could have been manic. I should not have been as confident as I was. I was like, oh, I know it.
我想有49个，因为我们查过，如果用上所有T、R和S字母，大概有127个。我查过了。有49个，但其中只有八个是有效的Wordle单词。让我想想我能不能凭记忆说出来。所以我们猜的cabin是其中之一。然后还有magic、panic、manic，其实我当时对那个词非常自信。也可能是manic。我不应该那么自信的。我当时想，哦，我懂的。
That was my hubris and arrogance there. It could have just as easily been manic and not panic. So yeah, cabin, manic, panic, magic, vapid. Vapid's a good one. There was two other that I'm going to forget. But one of them was cavil, I believe, which was C-A-V-I-L, which I looked up and meant to carp, which I know carp is a fish. I did not know that was a verb. And that, I mean, the listeners already heard this. I'm just repeating this. I was surprised that Paris is on the word list. I used that the other day and didn't even expect it to hit.
那真是我的傲慢和自大。它完全可能是manic而不是panic。所以，是的，cabin、manic、panic、magic、vapid。vapid是个好词。还有两个我给忘了。但其中一个是cavil，我想，也就是C-A-V-I-L，我查了一下意思是挑剔，我知道carp是一种鱼。我以前不知道它还是个动词。而且，听众们已经听过这段了。我只是在重复一遍。我当时很惊讶paris竟然在单词表里。我前几天用了它，甚至没指望它能中。
Yeah. Okay. All right. All right. So I'm going to have you play. So wait, can we do the actual real world first? No, no, no, no, no. I'm too, I'm too excited about the one that I have for you. All right. We're doing two back to back wordles here. This one's a fake one though. So, so earlier this week I had Connor play a word. I just picked a word and I'm like,
好的。行。行。所以我要让你来玩。等等，我们能先玩真正的Wordle吗？不，不，不，不，不。我太——我对我要给你的这个词太兴奋了。好了。我们这里要连续玩两个Wordle。不过这个是个假的。所以，本周早些时候我让康纳猜了一个词。我随便挑了一个词，然后我说，
start guessing. And I told him it was a proper noun and he got it in like two shots because of course I picked my name. It was like, you know, my vanity just really tripped me there. So your word today, Connor, it is not a wordle word. It's not on the list, but I will tell you this, it's a brand. So give me your first guess. And I'm going to send you, I have myself all set up here to send you the little Unicode results for each one of your guesses on Twitter. So it's a brand. All right. My first guess is a rose. Well, I guess this is a podcast, so I'll have to verbally describe it anyways. So Connor Guesta rose, and he got a hit on the O, but not in the correct place.
开始猜吧。我告诉他这是个专有名词，他大概两次就猜中了，因为我当然选了我自己的名字。就像是，你知道的，我的虚荣心真的害了我。所以你今天的词，康纳，它不是一个Wordle词。它不在那个列表里，但我可以告诉你，这是一个品牌。所以给出你的第一个猜想。我要把你每次猜词的Unicode结果发给你，我已经把一切都在Twitter上准备好了。所以这是一个品牌。好的。我的第一个猜想是arose。好吧，我想这是一档播客，所以我无论如何都得用口头来描述它。所以康纳猜了arose，他在O上面猜中了，但位置不对。
And everything else was a miss. Interesting. I was going to have a potentially N2, and I got excited when you said O in the wrong place. Because I also have a brand that is five letters that I would already choose for you. I can tell you it now. It's Exxon. E-X-X-O-N. That's freedom. But you didn't say E, so it's clearly not Exxon.
其他全猜错了。有趣。我本来可能会猜N2，当你听到O在错误的位置时我很兴奋。因为我也有一个五个字母的品牌，我已经为你选好了。我现在就可以告诉你。它是Exxon。E-X-X-O-N。那是自由。但你没说E，所以显然不是Exxon。
So all right. So it's just the O, correct? Yeah. Just the O. That's all. Okay. So here's the thing. I'm trying to think, should I actually try and start guessing brands? So like Just the L. That's all. Okay. So here's the thing. I'm trying to think,
所以，好吧。所以只有O对，对吧？是的。只有O。就是这样。好吧。所以事情是这样的。我在想，我是不是真的该开始猜品牌了？所以就像……只有L。就是这样。好吧。所以事情是这样的。我在想，
should I actually try and start guessing brands? It's like, like do hardcore mode, but also start guessing brands. I mean, I'm getting, I am being generous in that my, I am not giving you a word list of solely brands, which I feel like would be very challenging. I'm letting you use the regular word list, but I'm just telling you that the word that it's going to be is a brand. So I guess if you don't like unless if that one, the word ends up being one of those words, you're taking off the opportunity. So Mark Harris ended up getting a moist in two. I also got moist in two, but he already tweeted about it.
我是不是真的该开始猜品牌了？就像……玩硬核模式，但同时也开始猜品牌。我的意思是，我很慷慨，我的……我没有给你一个全都是品牌的词表，我觉得那会非常具有挑战性。我让你使用常规的单词表，但我只是告诉你最终的答案会是一个品牌。所以我想如果你不喜欢……除非那个词最终是那些词之一，否则你就失去了一个机会。所以Mark Harris最后两次就猜中了moist。我也两次就猜中moist了，但他已经发推特了。
I got, I got, I got it in one because I figured out just from what he had. That's cheating. I mean, it was the equivalent as if I got it in two because he got, I knew what, what I knew that he played our starting word,
我……我……我一次就猜中了，因为我光凭他有的线索就推断出来了。那是作弊。我的意思是，这跟我两次猜中是一样的效果，因为他猜了，我知道他、我知道他玩的是我们的起始词，
and so I knew what he got for the first one. But I feel like you and I have a pretty good rate of getting it in two or three. No, no. So I've only ever gotten it in two once, and that was moist. But I feel like we have a pretty good rate of getting it in three. But anyways, but anyways. Getting it in two, though, the difference emotionally, how that feels oh yeah yeah yeah it is i think i've maybe i've gotten it in two more than you but i've definitely gotten i definitely had more varied performance than you yeah i i saw someone that that had a total miss on their i showed you that that the one that you
所以我知道他第一个词猜了什么。但我觉得你和我的命中率挺高的，基本上两三次就能猜中。不，不。所以我只有过一次两次就猜中的，那就是moist。但我觉得我们三次猜中的概率挺高的。不过总之，不过总之。不过两次就猜中，情感上的差异，那种感觉……哦，对，对，对，确实是。我觉得可能……我两次猜中的次数可能比你多，但我的表现绝对比你起伏更大。对，我看到有人完全猜错了一次，我给你看过了，你
got it in three someone had a total miss and then their next guess total green yeah that was light i think that was the one that was on light anyways should we go for i mean if o is not in the middle it's either going to be a word like founder hound or should we go for something that has like a tch because we don't actually have... Oh, actually, wait. Isn't there a... Oh, no. I was going to think of that
三次猜中的那个，有人完全猜错，然后紧接着下一次全绿。哦，那是light，我觉得那是关于light的词。不管怎样，我们该选什么……如果O不在中间，它要么是一个像founder或hound这样的词，要么我们应该找一个带有tch的词，因为我们实际上没有……哦，其实，等等。难道没有一个……哦，不。我正想那个
automotive company Bosch, B-O-S-C-H. Would have been a good guess, but we don't have an S. It would have been a good guess. Let's just go with... We're going to go with the guess of the word notch. N-O-T-C-H. Well, I've got good news for you and bad news for you
汽车公司Bosch，B-O-S-C-H。本来是个不错的猜想，但我们没有S。那会是个好猜想。我们就选……我们要选notch这个词。N-O-T-C-H。好吧，我有个好消息要告诉你，也有个坏消息要告诉你，
the good news is that there is an o in the second letter the bad news is everything else is a miss okay so you've got an o in the second place. I was going to say there was a brand, Pocky, right? That Japanese sort of wafer. And that's like P-O-C-K-Y, I think. But there's no C in it now. That sucks. Never going to get it. He's never going to get it.
好消息是第二个字母有个o，坏消息是其他全猜错了。好吧，所以你在第二个位置猜对了一个o。我本来想说有个品牌叫Pocky，对吧？那种日本的威化饼干。我想大概是P-O-C-K-Y。但里面没有C。太糟了。他永远也猜不出来。他永远也猜不出来。
Do I know this brand? Oh, yeah. You know this brand. Okay. I'll get it then. What are we talking about? So clearly Bryce has gone for atypical letters. So that's what we got to switch our strategy to here at this point.
我知道这个品牌吗？哦，对。你知道这个品牌。好吧，那我能猜出来。我们在说什么呢？所以很显然布莱斯选了非典型的字母。所以这就是我们在此时必须转换策略的地方。
The question is, is it four consonants or is there an I and a Y? I say we just try. So is there a way to get an I and a Y guessed at the same time? Let's do it. You know, it would be really evil if the brand is O is UFOs. O-O-F-O-S. But there's no S. So it can't be UFOs. And I'm actually wearing UFOs right now. UFOs are running recovery sandals. Yeah, I know. I have I have a pair of those. Yeah, they're wonderful. Yeah, I got them. I got them the week that I moved to New York. I got a pair of those recovery
问题是，它是四个辅音，还是有一个I和一个Y？我说我们直接试试。那么，有没有办法同时猜出I和Y呢？我们试试吧。你知道的，如果这个品牌是UFOs，那就太恶心了。O-O-F-O-S。但没有S。所以不可能是UFOs。而且我脚上正穿着UFOs呢。UFOs是跑步恢复凉鞋。对，我知道。我有一双。对，它们太棒了。对，我买的。我搬到纽约的那周买了一双。
shoes. Oh, we haven't guessed an L. So oily. What are the words that coily? No, we already guessed C. Doily. That's a word, right? D-O-I-L-Y. Actually, let's just... I'll check the word list. No, no. Doily's on the list. All right. Let's go with doily. Let's see how far we get. So there is an L hour but not in that place oh that's that's very useful here's a problem and i'm not sure if i should be maybe you can well you don't have uh you don't have my program though yeah are you using your program no no i'm not that's because it's i'm just i i have it set up to be able to use it
鞋。哦，我们还没猜过L。所以oily。有什么词是coily的？不，我们已经猜过C了。doily。那是个月，对吧？D-O-I-L-Y。其实，我们直接……我查一下单词表。不，不。doily在表里。好吧。就选doily。看看我们能猜到哪一步。所以我们有一个L，但位置不对。哦，那太……那太有用了。这里有个问题，我不知道我该不该……也许你可以……不过你没有……不过你没有我的程序，对吧？是的。你在用你的程序吗？不，不，我没有。那是因为……我只是……我把它设置好了可以使用，
but i think the problem with using proper nouns i'm sure there is at least one word or a couple words but like i'm not actually sure there are many valid words left that i can guess like in in the dictionary yeah you may be no i'm sure that there's still i'm sure that like given that set of words that you have i I'm sure that you have options. I'm not sure. Like, cause I haven't guessed U yet. So I'm almost positive. The problem is, is that I have guessed both N and D.
但我觉得使用专有名词的问题在于，我确信至少有一个词或几个词，但我其实不确定词典里还剩下多少我能猜的有效单词。是的，你可能……不，我确信还有，我确信像你拥有的那组词，我确信你有很多选择。我不确定。因为我还没猜过U。所以我几乎可以肯定。问题是，我已经猜了N和D。
So I think all of the O U words are all gone, which means that it's probably a word that is like O blank U. And when you put the L in there as well. So actually, yeah, go to wineverygame.com and type in question mark O. Is this the thing that I should be using for Wordle? No, it's just an anagram solver. You want me to type in? Question mark O, question mark U, question mark oh question mark you question mark and then
所以我觉得所有的O U组合都没了，这意味着它可能是一个像O空格U这样的词。而且当你在其中加上L的时候。所以其实，对，去wineverygame.com输入问号O。这是我玩Wordle时应该用的工具吗？不，它只是一个变位词求解器。你想让我输入？问号O，问号U，问号……哦，问号U，问号，然后
type that in again for the prefix and then also filter like visually filter by ones that have an l in it and my guess is that it's like you've got yeah you don't have many options how many do i have um i think none that don't reuse some letters that you know aren't there none no no there are words but they just words that use letters that you know aren't in it yeah i mean that's so that's the problem is that is there actually a valid word i'm trying to think um yeah there's plenty of valid words you might might just have to know, but like an actual valid word that doesn't reuse. That's the thing is probably not. Maybe there's two O's.
在词首再次输入那个，然后还要按视觉筛选出包含L的词，我猜你的意思是……是的，你没有太多选择。我有多少个？嗯，我觉得没有不重复使用那些你知道不存在的字母的选择。没有，不，有那些词，但它们只是使用了那些你知道不在其中的字母的词。是的，我的意思是，这就是问题所在，到底有没有一个有效的词？我在想……嗯，有很多有效的词，你可能只需要知道，但一个真正不重复使用的有效词。问题就在于可能没有。也许有两个O。
Maybe I'm getting way too, um, maybe there's two O's. It could be that, right? Or there could be a U. I just, I love the one that for once there's a quiz on this show where, um, I'm not the one that's suffering where Connor's the one that's suffering where connor's the one that's suffering oh mogul m-o-g-u-l is that a valid word that's i'm gonna i'm gonna let you play it is it is it check it just isn't your is it on your win every game list um i know that mogul is definitely a word so there is that is that's a valid word that doesn't
也许我想得太多了，嗯，也许有两个O。可能是那样，对吧？或者可能有一个U。我只是，我喜欢这个节目难得有一期测验，嗯，受苦的不是我，而是康纳，受苦的是康纳，哦，mogul，m-o-g-u-l，这是一个有效的词吗？我要，我要让你玩它，它是，是吗？查一下它是不是在你的“赢得每一场游戏”的列表上，嗯，我知道mogul绝对是一个词，所以，这是一个有效的词，它没有
use any repeats you have the same thing as before uh there's no there's no u um the l is still out of place i just thought of rolex but that's definitely not valid you had you had you had a good idea before i'll tell you that you had a good idea before you didn't pursue it but you had a good idea before two l's hey or two o's xerox is also not gonna be it xerox is an interesting one i should xerox is actually xerox is actually a valid um scrabble word i'm not sure if it's in the probably it's not in the wordle dictionary but um um i'll check if it is that's gonna be a miserable day oh my god it is there that's going to be a miserable day. Oh, my God, it is. There's also like I can't remember if it's a dating app called Zoosk.
使用任何重复，你和之前有一样的东西，呃，没有，没有u，嗯，l还是在错误的位置，我刚才想到rolex，但那绝对无效。你之前有一个好主意，我得告诉你，你之前有个好主意，你没有坚持下去，但你之前有两个l或者两个o的好主意。xerox也不会是它，xerox是一个有趣的词，我应该，xerox实际上是一个有效的，嗯，拼字游戏（Scrabble）词，我不知道它是不是在Wordle字典里，但是，嗯，我会检查一下如果真是那样，那将是悲惨的一天。哦，天哪，真的是。还有像我记不清是不是有个约会软件叫Zoosk。
Z-O-O-S-K, I think. And I'm at four guesses. So basically I can get one more info guess. Yeah. So let's go. We're going to go for two O's. Yeah. Ideally like an L in the middle because I don't have like a Y or something to put at the end
Z-O-O-S-K，我想是的。我已经是第四次猜测了。所以基本上我还能再猜一次获取信息。是的。所以我们走吧。我们要选两个O。是的。理想情况下，中间有一个L，因为我没有Y或其他东西可以放在最后
it's unlikely it's going to be L-O-O consonant consonant so you know that the L can't be in the last it's either the first or the third so yeah my options are like L-O-O something something or O-L-O in the middle
不太可能是 L-O-O 辅音 辅音，所以你知道 L 不能在最后，要么在第一个，要么在第三个，所以是的，我的选项就像 L-O-O 某某或者中间的 O-L-O
but then I don't actually think that there's a word. Search me that on your win every game. Is there a question mark, O-L-O question mark? Question mark, O-L-O question mark. And like obviously color. And there's a couple others, I'm sure. Colon, you know, et cetera. But like is there one that uses just Q-W-P- K, F, Z, X, V, G, and J?
但随后我实际上不认为有这样一个词。在你的“赢得每一场游戏”里帮我查查。是不是有个问号，O-L-O问号？问号，O-L-O问号。还有很显然是color。当然还有其他几个，我确信。Colon，你知道的，诸如此类。但有没有一个只用了Q、W、P、K、F、Z、X、V、G和J的词？
Not even close. So like, I don't even know how to go about guessing. So it's like in order to guess a word, I'm not actually going to be able, I'm only going to be able to get one extra consonant. So I'm going to have to choose one. So like I could guess Polka, P-O-L-K-A, that gets me the O, the L, not the second O, and also reuses an A. So really what I should do is try and just find any brand at this point, because other brands should be guessable. Yeah, I'll let you guess. I'll let you guess any brand. How about any seemable word?
差得远呢。所以，我都不知道该怎么猜。所以，为了猜出一个词，我其实做不到，我只能多得到一个额外的辅音。所以我必须选一个。比如我可以猜 Polka，P-O-L-K-A，这样我得到了 O、L，没有第二个 O，还重复使用了一个 A。所以实际上我应该做的是，在这个时候试着找任何一个品牌，因为其他品牌应该是可以猜的。好吧，我让你猜。我让你猜任何品牌。任何看得过去的词怎么样？
Can I make a word up? Like, you know, Polob, P-O-L-O-B or something like that. P-O-L-O-B. That's not my actual guess. Not my actual guess, for the record. And you'd have to even let me know if something like that would be allowed. So what should I be going for? I feel like I should definitely go for the second O.
我可以自己编一个词吗？比如，你知道的，Polob，P-O-L-O-B之类的。P-O-L-O-B。这不是我真正的猜测。声明一下，这不是我真正的猜测。而且你还得让我知道这样的词是否被允许。那我该选什么呢？我觉得我绝对应该选第二个O。
I should just try and get O-L-O. I'm going to heavily edit this down. I know you are. This is going to take some time. I mean, I'm looking at like the O-L-O words and see if there are any that give you like one. You know, you could do, there's a word here, polis, which would reuse an S,
我应该试着找 O-L-O。我会把这段剪掉很多。我知道你会的。这需要一些时间。我的意思是，我正在看 O-L-O 的词，看看有没有哪个能给你一个。你知道的，你可以这样做，这里有个词叫 polis，它会重复使用一个 S，
but you know, what's your guess? Oh, polos? Like P-O-L-O-S. Yeah, polos. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. That's not bad. Although the cynic in me is like the only reason Bryce is throwing you that bone
但你知道，你猜的是什么？哦，polos？就像 P-O-L-O-S。对，polos。对，对，对，对，对。那还不错。尽管我体内的愤世嫉俗者觉得布莱斯给你抛出这个骨头
is because it doesn't help you at all. Other than the fact that I know the cynic in me is like the only reason Bryce is throwing you that bone is because it doesn't help you at all. Other than the fact that I know that it'll give, it'll give me, it'll lock in that the L is in the first or third and whether there's another O, you know what? Let's do it.
只是因为它对你一点帮助都没有。除了我知道我体内的愤世嫉俗者觉得布莱斯给你抛出这个骨头只是因为它对你一点帮助都没有。除了我知道这会给我，这会给我，这会锁定L是在第一个还是第三个位置，以及是否有另一个O，你知道吗？我们上吧。
Let's do it. Polos. Polos is a valid word. I have, I have good news for you, which is that the L is in the right place. And there's no P. And no second O?
上吧。Polos。Polos 是一个有效的词。我，我有个好消息要告诉你，那就是 L 的位置是对的。没有 P。也没有第二个 O？
There's not a second O in the place that you guessed it. But if it's an O in the wrong place, that should be yellow. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. I'm sorry. You're correct. Wow. Look at that. Bryce at the finish line almost tripped and lost the game because he doesn't know how to give me the correct information. You're right.
你猜的位置没有第二个 O。但如果是一个位置不对的 O，那应该是黄色的。哦，对，对，对。对不起。你是对的。哇。你看。布莱斯在终点线差点绊倒并输掉游戏，因为他不知道怎么给我正确的信息。你是对的。
You're right. It's green, green, yellow. Yeah, green, green, yellow. Yeah. So he did actually message me the wrong thing. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's true. All right.
你是对的。是绿色、绿色、黄色。对，绿色、绿色、黄色。所以他确实发错了信息给我。对，对，对。确实如此。好吧。
So at this point, we actually should be able to guess it. We know it's blank O-L. So let's see. Blank, blank. So you know that the O is either in the first or the last. So you know you've got, you know. And so that's actually interesting are there any brands that start with ool uh the only one that comes to mind which is not ool it's ook is ooklas the uh
所以在这一点上，我们其实应该能猜出来了。我们知道它是 空格-O-L。所以让我们看看。空格，空格。所以你知道 O 要么在第一个，要么在最后一个。所以你知道你已经有了，你知道。这其实很有趣，有没有以 ool 开头的品牌，呃，唯一能想到的不是 ool 而是 ook，是 ooklas，那个呃
speed um the speed test for your browser that most people use and remember this is this is a well known brand like yeah so that wouldn't be it you will know it and yeah ool is pretty unique that i'd have to like i'd have it'd be have to be a pretty big swing and a miss i apologize listener if you're screaming at your earbuds right now being like come on how can he not know the ool brand so we will give up on that so then if you've got ol andL and then if you've got question mark, O-L, question mark, O, what could it possibly be? Oh, I know. I just typed out underscore O-L underscore O. And in my head, I was thinking polio.
速度，嗯，大多数人使用的浏览器测速工具，记住，这是一个众所周知的品牌，所以不会是这个，你会知道的，ool 非常独特，以至于我必须得，这得是一个相当大的失误。听众朋友们，如果你们现在正冲着耳机尖叫，觉得“拜托，他怎么会不知道 ool 这个品牌”，我向你们道歉。所以我们将放弃这个。如果你有 ol 和 L，然后如果你有 问号、O-L、问号、O，那它到底可能是什么？哦，我懂了。我刚才打的是 下划线-O-L-下划线-O。我脑子里想的是 polio（小儿麻痹症）。
But then as soon as I realized, oh, right, we have no more vowels. Connor is going to lock it in on the six guests with Volvo. You got it. Nice work. Nice work. I'm so proud of you. That was totally worth the substantial amount of editing you're going to have to do. Yep.
但随后我一意识到，哦，对了，我们没有元音了。康纳将在第六次猜测时用 Volvo 锁定胜局。你猜对了。干得漂亮。干得漂亮。我为你感到骄傲。这完全值得你接下来要进行的大量剪辑工作。是的。
Not a bad one. I still actually think Exxon's a bit worse. I do think Exxon's worse. Yeah, but don't worry. I got worse ones coming for you. All right. Are we doing the actual Wordle now? All right. We're going to do the real Wordle now. Are you going to screen share? I wasn't even joking when I said this podcast is just about Wordle now. All right, all right.
这不算太糟。我其实还是觉得 Exxon 稍微更糟一点。我确实觉得 Exxon 更糟。是的，不过别担心。我还有更糟糕的要留给你。好啦。我们现在要玩真正的 Wordle 了吗？好吧。我们现在要玩真的 Wordle 了。你要共享屏幕吗？当我刚说这个播客现在只是关于 Wordle 的时候，我可一点也没开玩笑。好啦，好啦。
You know what the tricky part is, though? Oh, actually, so let's do a quick analysis. Let me, because I was typing it in, but I haven't run my Wordle program. So it was a Rose Notch, Doily Mogul, and Polos. Yeah. Let's see how many actual words. So yeah, so after the the third guest doily
你知道棘手的部分是什么吗？哦，事实上，让我们做一个快速分析。让我，因为我刚才在输入，但我还没运行我的 Wordle 程序。所以那是 Rose、Notch、Doily、Mogul 和 Polos。是的。看看有多少个真实的词。所以，在第三次猜测 doily 之后
there were only two words that i could have guessed um the first one was woeful w-o-f-u-l and that's not a valid wordle word and then the other one is mogul so i got i guessed one of the two words after i guess mogul there are no, my program shows that there's zero words left in the Wordle dictionary. So that's the hard part about doing brands is that I'm then forced to start reusing letters. But yeah, you helped out with polos. That is a polis. That's worse than wagon or whatever I said. Thanks for listening.
我只能猜出两个词，嗯，第一个是 woeful，w-o-f-u-l，那不是一个有效的 Wordle 词，然后另一个是 mogul，所以我猜中了其中一个词。在我猜出 mogul 之后，没有了，我的程序显示 Wordle 字典里剩零个词。所以使用品牌的难点在于我被迫开始重复使用字母。不过是的，你在 polos 上帮了忙。那是 polis。这比我说的 wagon 还要糟糕。谢谢收听。
We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们希望你喜欢本期节目，祝你有美好的一天。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。